supongamos que tú eres un agricultor de
sandías y quieres hacer un estudio sobre
la densidad de semillas en tu sandías
tal vez porque tienes planes de criar
sandías que tengan menos semillas y
bueno claro no vas a no vas a partir
todas las sandías para ver si esto está
pasando porque sería absurdo tú
obviamente quieres vender al menos la
gran mayoría de sandías así que
solamente quiere es una muestra un
muestreo con algunas sandías para ver
qué está pasando con la cantidad de
semillas está disminuyendo sigue igual
que pasa y después esperar poder tener
algunas estadísticas de las muestras
unas estimaciones decentes de los
perímetros para la población así que
iniciamos con esto digamos que tú tomas
estos cubitos una muestra arbitraria de
tus sandías y cuentas la cantidad de
semillas en cada cubo ajá y lo que
obtienes son ocho muestras en las que
encontraste digamos en la primera cuatro
semillas en la siguiente tres semillas
en otros cinco o siete
29 11 y 7 ajá
estas son las muestras está esta es la
población de todos los cubos la
población de todos los cubos podríamos
pensar en cubos de un centímetro solo
para facilitar la vida y esta es una
muestra muy pequeña la que estamos
tomando tal vez tal vez en el total haya
en el total de la granja haya un millón
no lo sé supongamos un millón esto sería
en mayúscula un millón sería en
mayúscula y digamos que n minúscula es
igual a 8 sólo para facilitar la vida en
matemáticas ahora vamos a pensar en qué
estadísticas podemos medir a ok la
primera que usualmente medimos es la
tendencia central y esa es la media
aritmética pero aquí estamos intentando
estimar la media poblacional entonces
obteniendo la media la media del
muestreo vamos a obtener la media
poblacional y cuál es la media del
muestreo qué será
y lo único que debemos hacer es sumar
estas medidas y dividirlas por el número
de muestras que tenemos entonces voy a
sacar la calculadora
entonces lo que hago tal vez no tal vez
no no la necesito veamos aquí 4 13 775
es 12 12 719 19 2 es igual a 21 más 9 es
30 más 11 es 31 141 7 es 48 en total
sobre 8 y eso ya es bastante directo
cierto 48 dividido entre 8 es igual a 6
por lo tanto la media del muestreo es
igual a 6 es nuestra estimación de lo
que podría ser la población pero pero
también queremos queremos pensar en en
cuánto cuánto en nuestra población
cuánto varía de la de la media cuánto
varía de la media entonces podemos
intentar estimar la varianza poblacional
calculando la varianza del muestreo
entonces vamos a calcular la varianza
imparcial del muestreo espero que a
estas alturas estemos familiarizados o
estemos convencidos de por qué dividimos
entre n menos 1 entonces vamos a
calcular la varianza imparcial y si
hacemos eso
que vamos a obtener pensemos ok aquí va
a ser esto será igual a 4 menos 6 al
cuadrado más 3 menos 6 al cuadrado más 5
menos 6 al cuadrado más 7 menos 6 al
cuadrado más 2 menos 6 al cuadrado más 9
menos 6 al cuadrado más 11 menos 6 al
cuadrado más 7 menos 6 al cuadrado
finalmente y todo esto dividido no entre
8 no entre 8 y recuerda que queremos la
varianza imparcial entonces vamos a
dividir entre 8 menos 1 así que vamos a
dividir entre 7 esto será igual a la
varianza imparcial lo voy a denotar así
para que para que quede en claro que
estamos dividiendo entre n minúscula
menos 1 y será igual a vamos a hacer
esto cuatro menos seis es igual a menos
dos y al cuadrado es igual a cuatro
positivo cuatro positivo ahora tres
menos seis es igual a menos tres al
cuadrado es igual a nueve
5 - 6 es igual a menos 1 al cuadrado es
igual a 176 es igual a 1 al cuadrado es
igual a 12 - es igual a menos 4 al
cuadrado es igual a 16 9 menos 6 al
cuadrado es igual a 9 y después 11 menos
6 al cuadrado es igual a 25 25 7 menos 6
al cuadrado es igual otra vez a 1 más 1
y todo esto dividido entre 77 así que
sumemos esto 49 es igual a 13 1 es igual
a 14 más uno es igual a 15 más 16 y 31 9
igual a 4025 igual a 65 y 166 y 66 sobre
7 esto lo podríamos dividir o podríamos
simplemente a esto sería igual a 99
3 sobre 7 o podemos ponerlo en forma
decimal
veamos 66 dividido entre 7 es igual a 9
puntos 42 entonces aproximadamente 9.43
aproximadamente 9.43 y ok ahora eso nos
dio nuestra varianza imparcial del
muestreo como podemos calcular nuestra
desviación estándar queremos alguna
manera para obtener la estimación de lo
que podría ser la desviación estándar
del muestreo y usando lógica es
razonable decir que esta es nuestra
varianza imparcial es nuestra mejor
estimación de lo que la verdadera
varianza poblacional es entonces cuando
pensamos en parámetros poblacionales
para obtener la verdad la desviación
estándar poblacional simplemente vamos a
tomar la raíz cuadrada de la varianza
poblacional entonces si queremos obtener
una estimación de la desviación estándar
muestral sólo tomamos la raíz cuadrada
de la varianza imparcial eso es lo que
vamos a hacer así que
vamos vamos a definirlo de esta manera
la desviación estándar muestral será
igual a la raíz cuadrada de la varianza
muestral ajá será la raíz cuadrada de la
varianza muestral que es esto será la
cantidad de la raíz de esta cantidad
entonces raíz de la segunda respuesta
aquí a esto así que será a 3.07
aproximadamente así que aproximadamente
3.07 ahora bien a continuación te diré
algo que no es muy intuitivo pero espero
sea de tu agrado entonces sobre esto
sobre esto ya habíamos hablado antes ya
habíamos hablado antes y se han hecho
simulaciones para mostrar que esto es
una variante imparcial de varianza
poblacional cuando dividimos entre n
menos 1 y eso es algo es un buen
comienzo porque cuando tomamos la raíz
cuadrada
es un buen comienzo aunque dado que la
raíz cuadrada la función raíz cuadrada
no es no es lineal entonces la
desviación estándar muestral que es
igual lo escribo desviación estándar
muestral desviación estándar muestral
esto es igual es igual a la raíz
cuadrada
de nuestra varianza imparcial muestral
entonces a nuestra varianza raíz
cuadrada de nuestra varianza imparcial
muestral desde igual a 1 hasta n
dividido entre n menos 1
así es como se define la desviación
estándar muestral y como la función raíz
cuadrada no es lineal lo escribo eso es
importante la raíz la función raíz
cuadrada no es lineal no es lineal
entonces resulta resulta que esto no es
una variante imparcial de la verdadera
verdadera desviación estándar
poblacional ajá puedes hacer
simulaciones de eso si es que te
interesa pero entonces tal vez tú
pienses ok entonces pasamos por todo
este lío dividimos entre n menos 1 aquí
para obtener un estimado de la varianza
imparcial para la varianza poblacional
porque no averiguamos alguna manera de
llegar a una fórmula sobre la estimación
de varianza imparcial de la desviación
estándar poblacional no es tan sencillo
porque para que la varianza muestral sea
imparcial simplemente dividimos entre n
menos 1 en lugar de n y eso funcionaba
para cualquier para de hecho para cual
distribución de probabilidad para
nuestra población pero resulta que para
hacer lo mismo con la desviación
estándar no es tan sencillo no es tan
fácil de hecho depende de cómo se
distribuye a la población así que en
estadística definimos la definimos la
desviación estándar muestral y la
utilizábamos basándonos en la raíz
cuadrada de la varianza imparcial
muestral pero cuando tú tomas esa raíz
cuadrada si te da un resultado imparcial
cuando estás utilizando esto para llegar
a un estimado para la desviación
estándar como te digo no es muy sencillo
pero bueno nos vemos